remplir son caddie et passèrent à la
caisse une équation parfois compliqué
pour certains budgets rien que mon mari
qui travaille et
donc on n'en fait pas s'en sortir avec
avec tous les dépenses des factures et
où on a des petites retraites voilà ap
avec allouagne et avec toutes les
factures à payer tout
on ne vient pas tous les jours mais ça
m'arrive de temps en temps à la fin du
mois sa peine divisée de mission passent
ici on achète ici c'est mieux car dans
cette épicerie de bourges les produits
sont proposés à prix cassés cinq fois
moins cher qu'en supermarché la
structure est gérée par une association
berruyères elle s'approvisionne en
grande partie à la banque alimentaire
ici sur une bourde au café qui est à 3
euros 50 voire 4 euros sur un
supermarché donc les gens peuvent ici sa
provision avec 50 centimes l'an passé
l'épicerie a aidé près de 5000 personnes
soit 15% de plus que l'année d'avant ces
bénéficiaires ont désormais des profils
variés
personnages et avec bien sûr les niveaux
de retraite qui n'augmentent pas bien
sûr et les familles les familles les
femmes y apportant notamment les
monoparentales à ce phénomène qui touche
la société et les jeunes les jeunes bien
sûr qu'ils ont très peu de traits pas
2000 l'association réserve ses produits
aux plus précaires sous conditions elle
vise à terme leur accès à l'autonomie
financière